hi everyone Logan has received an Oscar
nomination for Best Adapted Screenplay
it's major accolade for a film in the
superhero genre and we have the exact
reasons why this script will win in the
writing category we'll get to those
reasons in a second but first welcome to
new rockstars news our deep dive into
all the biggest stories this week so
we're also gonna discuss the new footage
from Black Panther and the details that
gave us about the new weaponry and
technology of this movie as well as our
first look at Captain Marvel's costume
and why it's green and more oh my god
I'm Erik Bosse and joining me in my
superhero script book club this week ah
hello it's your old pal Sam for sure so
Molina had my wisdom teeth out last week
yeah we'll talk later about it Maude
Garrett Maude Garrett
well guys everyone welcome welcome to
this show let's get started with our top
story
Logan's amazing script this week the
2018 Academy Award nominations were
announced and among the five nominees
for Best Adapted Screenplay was Logan
and of course by Scott Frank James
Mangold who directed the movie and
Michael Green
now the other nominees in the category
are call me by your name the disaster
artist Molly's game and mud bound the
superior genre has historically been
snubbed by the Oscars usually only
scoring nominations for like technical
awards and visual effects things like
that sue is one of the few severe movies
with an Oscar win for was it makeup hair
styling yep now The Dark Knight
actually was somewhat of an exception of
this trend winning for Best Supporting
Actor for Heath Ledger and sound editing
and it scored a bunch of other
nominations well many of us argue that
it should have also been nominated for
its Screenplay Best Picture and Best
Director as a woman I would say in fact
many people believe that's why they
expanded the Best Picture nominees to up
to ten movies so that they could include
other movies the next Dark Knight that
comes along right try and get that next
document now after reading the
screenplay / Logan and after reading a
lot of the screenplays it's easy to see
why Academy voters consider it one of
the best scripts of the year there are
three specific excerpts said we're gonna
single out and analyze that show how
well-written Logan is and how its unique
among Hollywood screenplays these days
so let's dive in first on page 2 of the
script writer Scott Frank stepped away
from the scene and inserted a for a
paragraph note about how he wanted
fights to be depicted in the movie he
described how unlike a passive era
movies the violence of Logan would be
more grounded with Logan and other
characters actually bleeding and tying
when they get hurt he wrote quote if
you're on the make free hyper
choreographed gravity to find city block
destroy and CGI F Athan this ain't your
movie that is the best sentence yeah
yeah we've talked to actually about this
excerpt before on this show but what I
love about this is even though this is
just a reader's note that doesn't
actually show up in the movie that you
see on the screen it it does so much to
establish what kind of story Logan will
be and any director who would like pick
up this script could just read this note
and take it to heart and then know
exactly how to shoot this movie even
though James Mangold was like the
perfect director for this story you
could give it to the hands of anybody
with as good of a Exorcist not anyone
hands of men gold
I just think guys it's such a ballsy but
also totally necessary move that sets up
how Logan will deconstruct the entire
superhero genre which is why critics
have been raving for it so much doing
that you just do it again you keep
calling it a superhero genre but what
Logan defined was that there is no
superhero genre superhero is just the
type of movie and then you can insert
said genre into it yes like you don't
call him cowboy movies right the whole
western genre is much larger than
Cowboys which Logan kind of proves but I
think that's a little bit of your point
to write that like previously people did
think there was a superhero genre and
yeah and then this excerpt actually is
is not only kind of saying like hey this
movie's gonna be a little different it's
actually saying hey when you read this
reader the movie that plays in your head
don't do superhero genre on it do oh my
god this is really happening and people
are really getting hurt and if anything
do Western which is definitely like but
I think that's probably why this is so
powerful right from page one essentially
it redefined the genre of the movie on
paper which that's what you mean I think
with like any director on paper
immediately is like well I can't make
the previous versions of what the
Wolverine franchise had done this is a
whole new thing literally the movie
right before this directed by the same
exact man it became a CJ F Athan near
the ending it became a totally different
movie and it was really disappointing
because what he had set up was extremely
interesting for a solo expended a change
and then this Logan was finally he was
able to do exactly what he wanted to so
I'm glad that it's gotten I got
nominated and this is a very good
example of why yeah that variable is the
thing that changed the directors and
director yeah I think a lot of times
with movies for people who aren't like
on the inside of the film industry
directors lead actors will get like the
credit for a movies success or failure
but really the whole movies existence
starts with the screenwriter and these
categories I think the movie that is the
best written movie of the year in my
opinion is the best movie of the year
because that's the most well told story
with the most clearly defined vision of
the story like I don't think you can
have a subpar script or a script
it's like this second or third or fourth
best of the year that is not also the
best movie of the year it always like
boggles me that some other like factors
kind of come in that's like oh was well
directed but it was like okay script
like to me it's all part of the same
direction of the movie is how well it's
written and we also when you read this
you're reminded how like even though a
screenplay is really just a blueprint
for a movie it's you're being told a
story you're being a bill to world
before your eyes and like you read so
many screenplays and sometimes
screenwriters will try to be like artful
and like no I'm gonna like show not tell
but sometimes like you really just need
to tell your reader and your creative
team exactly right story you want to
[ __ ] show not tell is very much a note
that's given to beginning writers
because they tend to over tell but and
then you end up with just like well you
explain every single detail here and you
didn't show anything really the best
being plays show and tell very well so
that a show is great for for subtlety
tell is necessary for clarity and
clarity is one of the things that people
think is on the nose writing and on the
nose writing is actually just are we on
the same page here and that's so
important on the screenplay level
there's nothing more on the nose or
literal than this part this passage you
know I think tell is just as important
when done skillfully yeah I'm interested
to know how often the screenwriter has a
particular vision and then the director
comes in and goes yeah so you're doing
black pivot you know so having the
director be also the screenwriter and
can see that vision all the way through
is a really big thing but you're right
having that whatever you think because
it has been happening for the last 10
years on think it because even though
this is a superhero movie it's not a II
to be here maybe yeah yeah this is just
a character you know but like look at
him in the more grounded light and I
think that's what is he has to
acknowledge because Wolverine has been
depicted and on screen so many times I
think he really has to take that step to
show this will be a different kind of
Wolverine movie do you guys have a
clearer definition at least for me and I
think some people in the audience would
baby like this too of when it comes to
screenplay adaptation is that talking
about taking old man Logan the comic and
adapting it or does that mean taking a
script and nailing it so well that it's
like no you deserve an award for this is
it talking about old man Logan well I
think because
nomination I think if it its nominated
in the adapted category as opposed to
the original category because we've seen
the character Wolverine on-screen
reports considered a sequel part of a
franchise so any yeah any movie that is
even if like if you consider Christopher
Nolan's Dark Knight to be kind of an
original take on it and maybe not even
adapted from Winnie one particular
storyline it is considered we considered
adapted screenplay because that those
characters in that world did pre exist
somewhere by another creator yeah
there's no it's not a quality different
so one's not better right like it's not
bad for screenplay to be adapted yeah no
I didn't think it was I just wanted a
clear definition yeah it's just a
different process if you're taking
instead of like world building from
square one from a blank canvas it's a
slightly different creative process well
I would say majorly different creative
process and like taking pieces out of
people create am like how can I best
arrange these pieces into a great
thrilling right different yeah well
let's move on to our second excerpt that
really stands out it comes from the most
heartbreaking twists from the movie when
Charles in the months and family are
attacked by x24 Logan's clone
specifically there's a moment Logan
returns to the farmhouse to find the
carnage realizing that his whole
existence has resulted in this darkest
possible fate for Charles and his family
of kind strangers that took care of them
the scene before this actually features
Charles is emotional confession of
accidentally killing the other mutants
and back in Westchester and he's
thinking he's talking to Logan but
actually is talking to x24 and that look
of shock on Charles faces Logan staffs
and it almost seems like Charles thinks
it's actually actually the real Logan
and in the script it makes it seem like
this is really Logan until they review
in the last second it's a clone the
writing uses this mistaken identity of
x24 to heighten the feeling of guilt
Logan feels in this moment and then you
see his point of view as he walks in the
house to see exactly what his decisions
have led to I'm getting emotional yeah
you re telling that story because I
forgot about that line he's his eyes
like it wasn't me or I didn't do it
right
like up so many times here yeah it's
like it doesn't matter at this point
it's moot yeah I think that this moment
actually to me even though I think that
opening scene is is you know amazing to
the reader I think this is actually the
nomination right here i to me the
performance a Hugh Jackman does is I
unparalleled and I think Hugh Jackman is
a huge part of why this movie worked but
only because he was given this
opportunity to do this because Hugh
Jackman has played Wolverine 71 times
this time he was finally able to achieve
what you know some writers refer to as
his heart of darkness moment which in in
screenwriting a a character you put you
write a character and you fall in love
with the character and like man that'd
be really fun to see you will Vereen get
to do this or your character do this but
the real moment that we actually want to
see but it hurts us as writers is the
worst nightmare of this character what's
the absolute worst thing that can happen
and a lot of people think as normally
death and obviously in a lot of
superhero movies the concern is is the
character gonna die but what's way
better for a character and character
building is what for that person is a
fate worse than death and this scene is
exactly in that moment because Wolverine
or Logan his whole life has thought I'm
a monster I'm deep down I'm actually
very bad and I'm not worthy of this life
and if anything he actually thinks death
would be a great escape for him but this
instead gives him okay what is your
darkest personalize to Logan what's your
worst-case scenario that the one person
that is still alive that thinks no you
are a good person opens his eyes and
sees that you are a monster and you have
killed him and that's the moment that is
rushing through his head when he sees
that that Charles has been stabbed he's
like oh no he thinks it's me and not
only is that so bad for me and it hurts
me so much but this is also the one
person in this universe that has said
this about mutants in general right and
he's like no I know overall if I know
one thing mutants are good because
Wolverine even though every thought is
bad he's good and it's like it's like
the Martin Luther King jr. guy right
there and you have suddenly made him
think was I wrong about right yeah the
poster child for mutant Redemption is
now proving me wrong
yeah and so that choice to give him this
I mean that's a screenplay level choice
and that I'm like that's perfect that's
the thing Logan has always needed to
face yeah and also since everyone kind
of saw twist coming at some point like
in this scene you're just like I
realize how bad it was gonna be like I
don't know what this I didn't I I just
remember weeping really hard in my seat
during yes part and I saw this this
movie we don't think into this but I saw
it with my dad and my dad's a big fan of
westerns and his dad my grandfather
passed away a year before and they loved
westerns so when they what was the movie
they kept bringing up the speech that
well Shane Shane yeah that was one of
their favorite movies to watch that was
like this really like it was a
complicated movie to watch in the
theaters yeah
please win it's such a good yeah well
let's uh let's move on to the final
excerpt that I want to single out now
it's on the second to last page it
depicts Logan's death scene but I just
it's amazing how like the he puts this
most climactic moment right at the end
of movie doesn't drag out the end of the
movie it's like the you're about to turn
on the last page and that's where the
most critical thing happens anyway so
human Hugh Jackman's human acting
ability was amazing in this moment he
definitely worthy of an Oscar itself
it's a shame he didn't nominate but
reading the script it's amazing to see
how so much this heartbreak is actually
in the words so for one look in Colleen
Laura calling Logan daddy at the time it
felt so authentic to me that I assumed
it was improvised by the actress but no
this is actually in the script the
father-daughter connection was always
intended to be between these characters
it was just never called out until this
final moment and then Logan's final
words this is what it feels like they're
preceded by this haunting piece of
exposition that I loved in his eyes
there is a flicker of wonder and you can
see how Jackman brings his faint look of
wonder to life the wonder refers to the
sudden sensation Logan feels of
mortality he's vis defied by this rush
of true vulnerability something he's
never felt before but he's been longing
for and it's finally delivered and just
with those few words you can see such
like his whole life passing before his
eyes and kind of this sense of release
and relief I love it it's all there on
the page I remember the few like I'm
minute or two after this when she pulls
the and makes the X and that's when I
lost it for something wrong it's a great
scene but like also just like screaming
previously already been crying like like
this whole scene I'm like oh it's really
getting to me her speech is getting me
and then you're getting me this moment
as usual we at new rock stars do not
abide by I just think this is an example
of like most of the time when you as I
said screenplays are our blueprints
they're not meant to be like books that
you read and they have their own kind of
literary value in this case this is a
literary piece of work and rereading it
you you discover new insights that you
weren't there before you could actually
read the screenplay and it's a
fascinating read I didn't think I would
be able to read the whole thing and once
I just took keps her knee was like a
page-turner of a script and it's so so
rare to find that I think that a lot of
this was the pressure to make the
perfect ending of such a long-standing
series yeah like with everything mm-hmm
there was I think this was a long time
coming and I think Hugh Jackman was a
big part of I think he was working with
James mangled he was a producer on the
film I'm sure he had several approvals
on the script I don't think he would
have done this movie if it was not a
true send-off and emotional set up not
just to the character as he is in the
text during the source material but as
we've gotten to know him on screen for
however many years 41 years it's worth
going back to do it like a third of a
second I was like you have to count all
the Christmas special
well we've we've done a lot of videos on
Logan on this channel you should go
check out our breakdowns of the film
when it came out we also did one about
how it should win an Oscar back so maybe
they can thank us for it South Kannamma
nation probably not we had very little
bit we compared it to another western
movie called Unforgiven which did a lot
to deconstruct the western genre and
point out how that wasn't a specific
genre that it's more of like a tone of a
movie and that won a ton of Oscars as
well back in the 90s but let us know
your thoughts about this and yeah
definitely read that screenplay even if
you weren't a film geek it's it's
definitely a page turn then it's did you
cry when watching Logan can you beat
Sam's 782 but let us move on to this
week's a trivia question and you know
what we're gonna keep things Logan theme
and there's no more tears to cry so it's
okay here we go
so in Logan what was the fictional brand
name of the popular energy drink that we
later learned was laced with anti-mutant
corn syrup that was poisoned by dr.
Zander Rice's company so looking for the
brand name it's fictional so not a real
one yeah this is we've write down our
answers just to stay on the theme that
we're we were just coming from the idea
of like redefining genres that's not
necessarily like always a good thing but
it definitely I it there's like a always
a year it's like always like 20 years
into a genre where you just need that
thing that reinvented exactly yeah and
it reminds me of the heist movie after a
while started to become like a very
stylized thing you know Ocean's eleven
or whatever and then I thought this was
Samms with the kiss on me
and but the the most recent heist film
that I loved was hell or high water oh
yeah yeah you see how it's like like
compare that to Ocean's eleven
previously it had been like the style of
heist film and then hell
it was like let's also try kind of the
western direction yeah but just that
sometimes are just the right moment
right pivot yeah heist can be an Logan
lucky came out earlier this year as
another it was like the same directors
Ocean's eleven I watched it it's a
redneck Ocean's eleven it's fantastic
it's so funny so well structured well
written Adam Drive off yeah if you can
get past I mean I'm a big fan but if
you're not tell us in a very weird
accent in the movie that a lot of
characters were talking weird accents
that movie but I kind of loved it a
little bit okay well later in the show
we'll reveal the answer to this trivia
question closes answer as decided by our
judges we'll get to do our goodbyes
whereas the loser will have to do our in
other news headlines and be funny on the
spot it's gonna be super stressful for
him but we're gonna move on because is
the new rock stars news and we cover all
the important stories from the week okay
everyone new footage of the upcoming
Black Panther film gave us an extended
look at the foot chase scene set in
South Korea now the scene gives us some
new details showing the amazing
technology of Wakanda and some
interesting features a black panther
suit so I thought let's zoom and enhance
on this footage shall we yeah the scene
begins with Sheree providing T'Challa
support by activating the car remotely
with a scanner on the hood and mapping
the car's structure as a holo display in
her lab back in Wakanda if you look
closely Shirdi has the car seat the
steering wheel pedal all laid out the
rest of the car just kind of projects
around her ear yes it's not a real so I
just exactly skim through the scene
because I'm trying to trying to be
careful while ëismí surprises for us to
do this theater it's possible that's not
about the car looks like on the inside
cuz I was like oh well Khan has got
their own cars and they look like this
on the inside only the steering wheel
everything else is mapped projection
around her hologram yeah that'd be cool
that would impact okay now I'm getting
us you know Sam mood I think what's
what's interesting if you look closely
in addition to the car as Sheree drives
you could see the city street to South
Korea the South Korean city street
passing by her outside also as a
hologram kind of like the x-men danger
room type thing how the hell is this
possible right if you think about this
how would you be able to also show a
realistic display real quick I think
it's important for people that haven't
watched this scene to clarify exactly
how this is playing out she is in her
lab she is not on the road
now but it looks very much like she's on
the road so here's we did a Photoshop
mock-up of like here's what you would
expect to see she's in a hologram and
the lab is behind her but instead way of
learning out is that suddenly she's
transported you know in in a visual way
at least as if she's on that road in the
city yeah as if there's like that live
green screen technology that they use
for Saturday Night Live's get just make
it look like you're right it was just a
green screen actually you see earlier in
the clip there's a hood scanner that's
on the hood of the car
that is Matt you know collecting all
this data and mapping it but I think
what it's saying is that this technology
is so elaborate and maps the surrounding
surfaces that this place is within as
well maybe kind of like taking a 3d
photograph of the street likes Google a
Google Street View I think it's a good
analogy for it like and then it
digitally reinsert this hologram car
from Cherise point of view in that
recreated the 3d environment that's
crazy
yeah but you can't you know make it that
cool cute little magnet you can't have
your gel car I can't have your jelly's
car gel it's just art stone it's like
the shoes yeah yeah it's just I think
we're gonna see this is just the tip of
the iceberg of the elaborate technology
that Wakanda has maybe not everyone this
is Cherie she is like the Tony Stark of
this of this world and she has special
access to things that she's like super
brilliant but I'm super excited to see
what other kinds of hologram projection
we see in this movie we also her okay
well next we also see how black
panther's vibranium suit is stored
inside of his necklace it extends
outward from that necklace it's his body
similar to Tony Stark's repulsor
crawling out from his wristwatch in
Civil War some interesting parallels and
it would be fun to see these characters
work together in the future but later as
enemies shoot it to Charla and the
bullets ricochet off his vibranium
sure he explains how each impact is
causing kinetic energy to build up
creating this purple glow inside of a
suit which she releases in the form of
this awesome shockwave that is so cool
yeah super powerful feature for his suit
to be able to convert a defensive
advantage his bulletproof armor into an
ffensive weapon I always thought that
was one of the coolest superpowers
there's a ball you know speed ball from
speed ball is the famous he does bad
stuff he does bad stuff your villain
he's a not by accident yeah mainly by
accident but he's some killer yeah you
take some kinetic energy can like you
can expel it out I always thought that
was so cool it's like so no matter what
if you get hurt and get punched it's
just like this is just gonna come back
and hurt you even if you try to shoot me
I can just absorb all that energy and
throw it right back at you I think
that's a really awesome power I'm glad
that at least they can't get speedball
you should work out there's too many
characters to play around with with the
MCU it'll take a while to get this one
there's a bunch of characters that
version of that and applying it to black
panther that's really cool to make him a
little bit more unique instead of just
claws and punching you know he needs a
little bit more than but I mean not that
Rand doesn't work yeah this must be part
of his new suit right cuz we didn't we
would have seen this used in Civil War
there's so many opportunities for him to
use and he did it so I think you know in
the trailer footage it looks like Sheree
is showing him a new suit it looks like
that's kind of the big selling point on
so Eric how much kinetic energy is
contained in a fired bullet it's
probably measured in joules I don't know
30 joules someone correctly on that so
let us know I actually that's a trick
question if it's stored its potential
energy right yeah while it's moving yeah
when the impact but once it gets stored
inside thus it was interesting she said
kinetic energy I'm sure there might have
been some physicists were like if it's
stored at the at that point the bullets
were done firing but when it's used
again it gets transferred in the moment
it touches his suit yeah it is at that
moment kinetic energy yeah yeah yeah
we're gonna get so corrected it's like a
berry Neil deGrasse Tyson is disrupting
this Mike no I do want to know like how
much power is he hitting these people
back with if it's let's say 10 bullets
yeah and comparing that to like a
grenade
that goes on that's a foursome oh yeah
yeah I'm velocity well let us know what
you guys think about these features
physicists yelling us are letting you
down and I want to know from you guys do
you think like Panthers sued has
substantially even more powerful than
what we've seen from Ironman I don't
know I remain might want to you know
copy some of the notes from her from her
playbook there but comment down below
and tweet us with your thoughts and as a
reminder subscribe to new rock stars for
all of our deep dives in the black
panther in everything you love thanks
guys but this is the new rock stars news
so let's move on to another story you
guys need to know about
okay everyone Captain Marvel this week
has released some new set photos of brie
Larson in costume as Carol Danvers and
despite the familiar red and blue with
the gold star costume Captain Marvel is
known from known for from the comics
this costume has a green color tone oh
my gosh now it could be that this
version of the costume is meant to look
like the original Captain Marvel marvel
as a Kree warrior who will be played by
Jude Law in the movie whose Kree
military uniform was green colored in
the comics Marvel's alter-ego dr. Walter
Lawson meets Carol Danvers eventually
passes on the mantle of Captain Marvel
to her the history of this characters
very long and very interesting a little
complicated and also you're seeing the
comic book or origin they specifically
said they're gonna change it for her so
that she becomes like not attached to
another her own they're gonna expedite
it and convince it so maybe what we're
saying here is Danvers in this green
colored costume as a throwback to that
Kree military uniform look the original
Captain Marvel wore and this maybe this
is just like her first look in the movie
before she like changes into her classic
look by the end of the movie kind of way
like Tony Stark in the first Ironman had
that weird goofy clunky suit and then
eventually got the more refined look
Marvel does a really good job with that
because it's it's fun to throw like a
nod to the history of the character you
got the mark 1 it was cool because I
read been re watching the Marvel movies
for for this year as we do on this
channel but re watching that it's like
it's kind of fun
because it's like we're I don't know
paying some respects I had another point
in there told me forgot what it was and
I know other characters have done that
too like you guys stole items for
Captain America when he was doing the
propaganda stuff in the first Avengers
movie which is really fun
you got the grey Hulk in multiple
versions of the Hulk depending on how
they decide to change what his face
looks like exactly these nods to the
different yeah original origin and I
feel like you're gonna get the helmet
too because he usually has like this
like skin-tight helmet with a little
little mohawk you probably get the blues
the iron fist one where you like goes
through so you're you're thinking that
this is a nod to the original suit and
not like this is Jude Law's costume and
then she happens to fit in it perfectly
yeah it's cama when she's in the forest
no that's your Ella can change your cue
that'd be stand out like a sore thumb
not so fast on the color of it and like
the wise I'm talking I want to talk
about the quality of this costume
because it's real bad that is not her
real hair is it that has got to be a wig
no way it's real like we're talking
about the cartoon it all looks fake to
me the costume in itself does it looks
like she's rocking up to comic-con what
here's a cosplay a good way to point out
what much talking about note the elbow
it like doesn't Bend well with her with
her it looks like it's 2 inches too long
for her the suit as well because it
bunches all the way down the legs
oh that is kind of interesting if you I
think they would then would definitely
agree that this is a proto suit and
early stage and she will eventually rock
the other one I think I like your idea I
also think it could be a potential nod
to her origin it could be like a flight
suit guys this junk room we didn't look
we didn't look properly but look look
well you're not supposed to there's junk
room oh wow yeah we don't know how Kree
biology works right they could have seen
every single other female tailored
costume ever
has there ever been that much room there
ever before where does she keep the gun
yeah you don't know what do you keep
yours but this is not make me excited
about the movie and I want to ask you
guys did this make you more or less
inclined to watch it be excited for it
we like money already so go see anyways
I what I've got to see Suicide Squad too
as well I think every Prix trailer set
photo that I've ever seen pretty moving
they need to be like what that's lame
like listen the one that always sticks
out to me is and well there's Doctor
Strange where it's like them running
down like a street and they do that
goofy jump and then just like land after
like six inches of a shocker for
spider-man homecoming it was like it was
shocking yeah or when Benedict
Cumberbatch played Smaug and he's
wearing that goofy suit with the
ping-pong balls on it's like oh wow I'm
like wow I was like they need to come
back what a great actor only yeah I
shouldn't have seen this because now I
won't be able to unsee it when I watch
the movie I think I think once Eric and
I played something like 20 questions or
something I guess the thing we had to
guess was Benedict Cumberbatch as smog
in the BTS footage where he's doing the
weird job
does that voice I wasn't a repulsive Oh
for me you know it wasn't that bad I
enjoyed it
she pulled teeth out of people's heads
and made a sphere out of it I don't go
right into something cooler at the end
but that is cooler than that well let us
know what you guys think about this
green costume and this interestingly
designed costume in the comments down
below tweet us at new rockstars of
course subscribe to this channel for
more coverage of all the upcoming Marvel
movies thanks everybody
ok moving on to our new rock stars news
lightning round
[Music]
you guys tweeted this questions and I'm
gonna fire them at my co-hosts who have
to answer them as quickly without
hesitation as possible is everyone ready
yeah here we go
Sam Star Wars Episode nine title
predictions that's from our friend Momo
at pure Mahana
why would you ask question mark the end
like Star Wars the end thank God other
scenes and the god in okay no re
watching Game of Thrones I guess this
person strim at Nicki
Raymond 71 we watching Game of Thrones
do you think Tywin knew that it was Arya
he was talking to at Harrenhal hmm
haven't got up today yet I wanted to say
I'm is friendly win but let's say no
because he is usually too drunk
he probably attention to detail yeah
Phillip at true scorn wants to know what
is your favorite fictional weapon powers
the first thing that came to my head was
Sylar on Kira
the other way that like he could just do
that and then take their take a noodle
Zachary Quintos finger little cricket
from men and black
[Music]
and for me what is the favorite thing a
fan has ever said to or about you from
at well first thing I should point out I
do not have fans I have people who
scream things that mean sometimes
they're nice but yeah I think my
favorite thing was like I I was gone on
vacation for a while and then I came
back and the top comment and I think it
was the most voted comment was hey that
fight that fat white boys back I think
I'm not human all right well let's next
up to take a look at what we got in the
pipeline coming out on this channel in
the next week
okay guys update we are now 119 days
away from the release of solo a Star
Wars story we're gonna keep track of how
many days guys and still new trailer no
teaser no first look displays a movie
we're gonna keep counting down the dates
that's gonna be our new and by the
numbers segment is how many days we have
left we're hiding yeah what are you
keeping from us well apparently they did
release some footage of it or some
images women at some French conference
but there's none of that leaked online
yeah this is a confusing guys just to
give you some thing to compare to four
months away compared to eight months
minimum for the other Star Wars movies
that have come out there's always eight
at least eight months ahead of time
they've released something something
anything yeah rest assured when that
trailer comes out we will do a breakdown
on it we will be talking about it a lot
now Sam's got another video and in the
works for next week I do Iron Man 2 I
watched it it is just a bridge movie but
it is not as bad as everyone remembers
so go watch it watch my breakdown I
found a lot of fun little secrets in
there that you'll enjoy in we're also
continuing our Game of Thrones rewatched
series next up on the list it seems like
we covered a lot of the big moments from
season 1 we're also gonna be talking
about moving on to season 2 the shadow
baby seemed Alessandra's magical dark
magical birth and what exactly happened
there what did it how did it change the
show there's so many questions I still
have about it so we got a we got a video
explainer coming out about that I think
you guys will enjoy and then we're also
gonna talk about a lot of you guys have
asked us about altered carbon the new
series coming out on Netflix that looks
very exciting it looks like kind of a
like Blade Runner or or something in
that vibe that it's gonna seems like
that big latest Blade Runner
2849 but not as maybe but no we're gonna
explain what this is and why you should
be excited about because I'm I am - I'm
very excited I'm looking forward to your
breakdown yeah so and we'll have some
more stuff coming out next week but now
comes the time for a 15-second shout out
where each of us has 15 seconds no more
no less you have to take exactly 15
seconds to shout out plug or ramble
about anything you want Sam why don't
you start alright timing everyone should
pick up if you have always been on the
fence of like Superman he's a boring
character I would be I would never want
to hear anything about him I never want
to know about him you should go read
Superman's secret identity the premises
in a real world where the comics exist a
boy gets the abilities to be Superman
and it's a story about it it's very
heartwarming I cried yeah but I cry at
everything yeah hopefully you were
timing at home stopped listening after
15 15 seconds shout out I would like to
shout out the YouTube channel lessons
from the screenplay I love that guy he
does some really interesting screenplay
analysis like we did with Logan today
and he just released a video about the
Avengers that broke up the act structure
and whether we need to do 3x or 5x to
look at movies definitely watch it Wow
13 seconds I was really impressive yeah
I'm on Netflix shannara chronicles'
season 2 has come out I watch season 1
because we got sent something at
SourceFed nerd and that was kind of cool
but a lot of Australians at unit
including like a fellow Brizzy kid who's
doing good things as well so I think
that alone is worth it because I have
Aussie pride being Australia Day mine
was gonna be altered carbon and then you
talked about it already
you just had 45 seconds of storage
another reason I tried counting if
you're in Los Angeles check out Erik
Bosse is improv West every week in
February is now all right well let's
finally move on to our trivia question
that we have before and we have the card
with the answer over here Devin will ya
toss that over to us and yeah and then
take mine okay so just to remind you
guys of the question in Logan what was
the fictional brand name of the popular
energy drink that we later learned was
laced with anti-mutant corn syrup
poisoned by doctors and erases company
lets him go down and see what we came up
with first up is slurm he drama fans
probably yes slurms mckenzie Maude said
surge which is really more more toxic
than what was actually in the movie Sam
said power up reference to things it's a
thing I think it was vague yeah Eric
said X juice x-men was popular yo lo
gonna make exit I think one of us got it
I think one of us got away tomorrow but
the real answer is hip no oral hype no
if no or hide knows who's cautious hip
know I searched you mean the real
company sir she does that a real thing
is it sir
it's like a mountain Dew problem energy
drink in the movie was effecting mutant
fertility so technically yeah that
wouldn't make you oh my gosh my
subconscious pieced that together yeah
somehow surge in Australia we barely
have we just got it back we're trying
have you got the worst yeah excuse well
might as the winner you'll get to do our
goodbyes you can make fun of our names
Twitter handles however you want first
we're gonna quickly run through some
other news headlines that were very
important this week that we didn't have
time for in our other segments now I'm
gonna have to read these at the end I'm
gonna have to like hold on make a joke
do you want me to read it out news like
while you think of the funny news as the
winner I will be your news reader and
deliver you the news that you really are
excited to hear for example Star Wars
the last Jedi novelization will include
a scene featuring Han Solo's funeral
what the hell funeral which didn't make
it into the film not in the novelization
are the funerals held by Chinese Theatre
houses after they dumped the movie Game
of Thrones actors Sean Bean will star in
an upcoming British TV series called
curfew in which it will be about a
post-apocalyptic street a street racing
say something about him dying the series
will go on for eight seasons Sean Bean
go on for eight minutes yeah
[Music]
Tom Cruise posted a first-look photo for
Mission Impossible six fallout showing
himself hanging from a helicopter they
were able to find a prop Department to
make a slightly smaller helicopter that
didn't engulf his tiny statue to a
window and he broke that's referring to
the radioactive decay he looks like now
that he's the entering his octogenarian
decade show in vain Oh what summer for
Dwayne the rock Johnson went off on a
Twitter critic who complained about
Jumanji saying that a video game
character shouldn't possess an item
after losing a life Johnson replied to
this critic to kindly go F himself hmm
and the level of civil discourse on
social media has hit rock bottom
the people's elbow Metropolitan Museum
of Art hosted an exhibition the yeah
Michelangelo sculptures with
Michelangelo from the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles walking around to a great
museum goers man was this publicity
stunt Cowabunga limbs are cool again
kids take it away mind guys thank you so
much for watching this week's episode of
new rock stars news we can thanks and
bash or if you want right but you don't
have to so what's your Twitter handle I
had Sam basher like you died three
minutes ago
hey Eric Eric vas ei vas it's in a name
to me
Philip Molina's you know you can only
really see his head next to me what he's
see-through and I'm Lourdes Garrett but
I didn't want to wash my hair today
that's why I'm wearing a beanie but now
you know that's worth the dab dab it no
hurry
it's the only way I do well comment down
below
tweet us at new rock stars like this
video share it around subscribed into
rock stars for deep dives into all the
stuff that you love guys thank you for
joining us see you next week bye Mike